you ready for this Michael yeah I'll
call you Mike alright so what got you
interested in player studio like money
was it my first incentive I just thought
it would be cool that something I
created can be on like the game's base
Buster what's going on bust well I'm a
college kid I'm at I'm a film major how
much time do you actually put forth to
the player studio effort a lot of my
free time actually I kind of I kind of
treat it as if it was my job welcome my
friend mr. Tracy hunt player studio
create or ah doing great just got off
work chilling out so what did you make
for planetside 2 I have made probably
about it a dozen or so decals three
helmets in game and probably about
another four to five waiting to go in
have you been doing this type of stuff
for a while this is something that you
just kind of picked up um I learned
Photoshop like laughs just last year so
yeah this is pretty much the first thing
I've done so when player studio came
around that's when I decided to apply
graphic design for like camos and stuff
like that but I really want to make
helmets so I just lied to learn 3d
modeling for that if there's anything in
the game that you would like to actually
create play your studio what would it be
I think the armor would be cool like
doing some of the composite our murders
so for the character is that what that
would be neat especially to be able to
do a set of armor that works with a
helmet you know to kind of complete an
overall look how much have you made
through players to do I would say right
at four grand 7800 about 12,000 what is
insane twelve-thousand dollars
what would you tell someone that is
interested in creating items for players
to do listen to people listen to the
advice that people have for you most
importantly make a thread on the forum
so don't just make something on your own
and submit it without ever letting
anyone look at it so that goes to show
you anybody out there and willing to put
in some time can cash in if they're
they're good enough so just a great idea
and a little bit of time